it's important to choose your role
models carefully try to choose guys who
are actually succeeding at something
other than just giving advice who can
actually have good conversations with a
variety of people on their podcast or
actually are making money in crypto or
have actually founded some company
that's doing well or who aren't just
like anonymous behind the scenes kind of
manisphere trolls
jeffrey miller welcome to the show
it's great to be here chris really
excited i just saw an article from metro
uk that's trending on twitter today
half of women aged 30 don't have
children for the first time since
records began
50.1 percent of women born in 1990
haven't had children by 30 according to
ons stats in comparison 57 of women born
in 1970
76
born in 1950 and 86 percent of women
born in 1941
all had at least one child by the time
that they turned 30.
that is crazy
it's a pretty big difference compared to
what's uh you know ancestrally normal
for humans i mean bear in mind you know
if people are reaching puberty at ages
12 to 14 and they're not you know
reproducing for another
like 16 to 18 years that's that's like a
hell of a delay
and you know my mom had me when she was
19 and that was pretty normal in the
mid-60s
so
on the one hand if you compare age 30
to a modern career track for women like
if you're an academic female trying to
get tenure
you know you might have like grad school
till age
26 or 28 post docs till age 30 get your
first assistant professor job 30
six years till tenure
you know you don't even feel financially
secure until your late 30s right but
biologically
you're like
i've been capable of having a kid you
know for years and years and years
so it's a crazy mismatch dude mismatch
is what we call it
mismatch dig into that what i mean
mismatch between what was ancestrally
normal like in prehistory versus what
the modern world has
so you know a simple mismatch would be
like what we eat
in terms of modern american diet versus
like paleo diet
um or how much sunshine we get if we're
indoors most of the day versus outdoors
but i think the mating
market mismatches are particularly
interesting and frustrating that's what
i've been fascinated by for the last
couple of months it's so
endlessly interesting i learned
i can't remember what book it was i want
to say maybe steve stewart williams book
uh the apo understood the universe
about the effect of a couple who have
been together for quite a while elected
not to have children they chose not to
but
find each other becoming increasingly
unattractive and can't really explain
why
is this an effect that's that you're
familiar with as well
this has not been very well studied but
i suspect there is
maybe
maybe some kind of instinctive thing
where
look if you're a human and you're in
like a long-term committed loving
parabond
you've been having sex with someone
week after week month after month year
after year and you're still not pregnant
under ancestral conditions that would
have been a pretty strong cue that
either you're infertile
or they're infertile but whatever the
case is
this might not be
a viable long-term relationship
reproductively and so
you know maybe there's some emotional
um
reaction to that that basically means
i'm going to divest from this
relationship
so that's another example of mismatch
once you have effective contraception
and you can have sex for years and years
and years and no baby
what's the emotional
impact of that we don't know i don't
think it's been very well studied but i
suspect it's
often not
good for relationships and people might
find themselves sort of
you know questioning their commitment or
falling out of love a little bit or
being a little less attracted to their
partner
and they might think like there's no
rational reason for this
i love them i'm committed maybe we're
married we have a mortgage together why
am i not into them anymore it might be
their body telling them
like
okay if you love them where's the baby
yeah well i mean it's because it doesn't
know that you've elected
to have this say the fact that we have
now been able to decouple having sex
from making children because of
effective contraception there's a
isn't there an equivalent that women
have
either just before giving birth or just
after giving birth that they can find is
it the smell of their partner
particularly
uh off-putting and it's something to do
with the protectionist strategy and then
perhaps the smell of their own family
family members are increasingly
attractive
yeah i've seen some stuff on that i
don't know how well replicated it is but
it would certainly make adaptive sense
that look
if you're
heavily pregnant or you've just like
where you might even be dilated and
there might even be like an infection
risk if you had sex might be bad for the
the baby
or in the first few weeks after giving
birth
like you don't want a woman to be like
super horny then
and so she might down regulate
how kind of
biochemically attracted to
husband she is but on the other hand she
might be more attracted to boyfriend or
husband and other family members in
terms of like i want cuddling i want
support i want emotional closeness and
intimacy
you know because that's what you need
when you've got a young baby
did you see this wall street journal
article that got shared by rob henderson
the other day agenda split over sniffing
a baby's scalp mothers get more
aggressive and fathers less so when they
inhale a chemical found in abundance on
infants heads
did you see this i didn't see it but it
it kind of makes sense because
like look when when you're a new dad
um
and you're used to having a lot of
testosterone and being kind of
aggressive
you really want to go
very very gentle
you know you really want to
tamper everything down because
and and this is one reason testosterone
levels drop when when men have have kids
is to like basically reduce the risk of
like
frustration
driven infanticide
you know
but on the other hand women might need
to get a little more protective
about the baby and have a kind of a mama
bear syndrome where
you know they might actually need to get
a little more vigilant for threats and a
little more assertive about dealing with
threats
as for many primate species infanticide
is a
big big problem from the violet
from the father and from other females
often how would it be adaptive to have
infanticide from the father
it depends on how confident he is he's
really the father
if he's highly confident you do not want
to kill your baby
but if you're
if you have a lot of doubt
um
then
this is like the grisly logic of
evolution and it's not it's not pretty
but
if you're pretty sure it's not your kid
then you'd really prefer that woman to
start cycling again and get fertile
again so you can have a kid with her
lions do this all the time kill lion
cubs that aren't theirs
and a lot of primates do this also
so yeah evolution's incredibly smart
about kind of managing
you know niceness versus um aggression
and
who do you seek
bonds and support with
all throughout you know the reproductive
cycle
that's fascinating is it right to say
that you're one of the ogs of applying
evolutionary psychology to sexual
dynamics do you think your the mating
mind book is
22 years old now yeah
i mean it depends on how you count it
right
the real og was darwin
darwin 1871 sexual selection um
book
amazing book it had a huge impact on me
and then you get a kind of long lull and
then in the 70s 1970s you got social
biology endio wilson who recently you
know died and then got cancelled um
postponed
mostly cancelled
uh and then you had people like
anthropologist don simons who wrote this
amazing book the evolution of human
sexuality in 1979
and that had a big impact on my little
field
evolutionary psychology which really
only got started in kind of the mid to
late 80s
and i got into it in grad school at
stanford circa 1988-89
and i'd been writing about um
sexual selection and human evolution all
throughout the 90s and then finally the
mating mind book came out
in the year 2000
um
five years later than i meant to publish
it but you know that's well writes book
uh that came out what 93 94 93 or 4 yeah
[ __ ] dude that is so good to go back and
read to go back and read that now it's i
did a i did a reading list a free
reading list last year and i had 10
books that were like you just have to
before you read anything else these are
the ones you have to read and bob writes
was was in there it's [ __ ] phenomenal
man yeah huge respect to him i did a
great podcast interview with him a
couple years ago he's still active
uh that book's a moral animal big impact
stephen pinker's books
throughout the late 90s
big
impact and there was kind of a golden
age of uh
like
popular science
based on evolutionary psychology and
kind of the 90s through early 2000s
before everything got super politically
correct and woke
i was going to say why do you think
that's
lacking some of those
discussions now
it's just extremely uh
difficult now to teach even to teach
undergraduates at most universities
about
like basic sex differences
you know i've taught a class on
psychology of human sexuality for about
20 years
and
you increasingly get blow back
from the undergrounds like complaining i
can't believe that professor miller is
reinforcing the gender binary and he's
like comparing male humans to males of
other species how dare he and
um it's gotten
like viciously and oppressively
political
particularly the last five years
and that's sad because
undergrads really want to understand
mating and sex and romance
and they're kind of being
denied that by
like a tiny percentage of people who
have a really strong political agenda
such a shame man like if i don't know i
think a lot i know that you're big into
existential risk which is my other
pet obsession
and um
that it really does feel like [ __ ]
being on the cusp of something
absolutely terrible and awful happening
that's just
completely getting in the way there's a
quote someone put on a youtube video a
while ago it's the loudest minority who
act like they're steering the ship
and [ __ ] if that's not true yeah
and so where where do undergrads go if
they're curious to understand this right
hopefully they're listening to like your
podcast hopefully they're reading jordan
peterson
um there's this whole parallel you know
intellectual ecosystem
that's grown up
that is much more honest
about these things than anything you get
in most american universities
let's say that someone hasn't looked at
dating and sexual selection through an
evolutionary lens before how do you
introduce it to them
i think one important thing to point out
is
neither sex is at fault
for
what's going on like both sexes men and
women both evolved
to do the best they can
given the reproductive incentives that
they faced
and so
neither sex is like
the norm that you have to compare the
other sex to
you often have men saying oh my god
women are so neurotic they're so anxious
they're so fearful like that's weird i
don't get it
well
if you take a woman's point of view you
know ancestrally if you're spending
a significant amount of your adult life
pregnant or with baby or with young kids
your the objective risk that you face
from predators
and pathogens and diseases
and starvation is just higher than what
men face so of course evolution
shifts your kind of you know
your risk tolerance
in a different direction and conversely
if women are like oh my god i can't
believe men are so into status and
aggression and dominance and why do they
do that it doesn't make any sense to me
well if you think who managed to
reproduce which kind of men attracted
women and had the the status and social
support and
the influence to be attractive
like given female hypergamy given female
mate choice
of course you know we're all descended
from males
who played that game avidly
so i think one
crucial kind of emotional insight from
an evolutionary perspective is
just to accept men and women and their
natures as they are
you know and then to figure out okay
given that
plus like modern culture and technology
how do you do the best you can
do not find it fascinating to see how
those predispositions that we have
towards certain things
that's the common thread that runs
through everything and then it gets
repackaged into
memes that we see in [ __ ] sitcoms and
products uh it's so
when you start to
understand the evolutionary
underpinnings of why people like the
things that they like and don't like the
things they don't like
it is it is kind of like seeing the code
instead of seeing the the game
yeah i i actually still like the uh the
red pill metaphor and there's like so
many things that have red pilled me but
probably evolutionary psychology was the
biggest red pill
for me just thinking
human nature and human culture as it is
is
the outcome of an extremely long story
a really long story way back into deep
time and the better you understand that
story
uh
the less puzzling
modern life is
and i
it's gotten to the point where like if
there's a married couple and they don't
have evolutionary insights into
their relationship and their their
values and preferences and and
what drives their reactions i think like
why would you handicap yourself that way
like it's really sad you'd be much
better to go back to like
read the moral animal by robert wright
rather than go to marital therapy
like do both but
jesus read something about human nature
if if you really care about your
relationship what do you wish more
married couples knew
i wish more married couples knew
that
you don't have to take your
emotional reactions nearly as seriously
as you typically do
for example
um
a lot of
people think
okay i know i'm not supposed to like
hit my spouse i'm not supposed to do
physical violence to my spouse and so if
i have an impulse to do that
i have to control that that's not
civilized that's bad
however there's a lot of other
um reactions we have that are basically
uh what economists call punishment
routines
like somebody else does something that
pisses you off
right and you have a reaction to punish
them to give some negative reinforcement
this can range from i want to hit them
to i want to cuss at them to i don't
want to talk to them for a day
to i want to complain about them to my
friends
or god forbid on social media
those are all punishment routines
the instinct to want to punish them
even over something that's
maybe objectively trivial can be very
strong
but we have this double standard where
like we go okay physical punishment
that's super bad we don't do that in a
civilized marriage
but all these other things
right are still considered kind of fair
game
even if they're objectively like a
massive overreaction
to what actually happened
i think conversely
if you understand like why we want to
punish
our mate for certain like transgressions
you then you can actually play with that
like you can make it funny you can kind
of playfully exaggerate it
my wife my wife diane and i do this all
the time like
um if she's pissed off at me for
whatever failing to do something in the
kitchen
instead of
taking it seriously and going oh my god
jeffrey you suck you're such a bad
husband
she'll start like mouthing
nonsense syllables
but in an angry way in kind of a
self-mocking way and so she'll be like
[Laughter]
and then i'll start arguing back
using like
my defensive
like nonsense syllables like
why can we do that because we're both
evolutionary psychologists and we both
know at some level
the desire to over punish for trivial
stuff is is just ridiculous and if you
understand
how ridiculous it can be
then you can make
uh fun of your own reactions
and then you're actually like closer to
each other
because like i have the faith that she
has enough self-insight
that she can mock her own like feminine
programming yeah
and she has confidence i have enough
insight into my sort of masculine nature
and programming that i can make fun of
it
and
by contrast you go to marital therapy
most therapists will be like you all
have to be a hundred percent earnest
all the time about your feelings and you
have to take your feelings seriously and
like express them
and
and work through them and talk it out so
diana if you were angry that jeffrey had
used the source and not put it away and
you felt upset about it then this is
justified we do not have any unjustified
feelings in this that's [ __ ]
interesting i've never been to
counselling uh
but i imagine
in movies where i've seen it that's what
they do
yeah and it's just
very few good role models in movies or
tv about how to manage these things like
you'll almost never see somebody in a
serious adult drama
actually make fun of their own reactions
in a kind of wise and insightful way the
only time that you would ever see it is
kind of the ditzy
female classic american ditzy suburbs
early 30s still not married like wine
ant
type lovable
like always the bridesmaid never the
bride type one like oh here i go again
losing my [ __ ] about something that
doesn't really matter which is kind of
touching the reason that people laugh at
it is the fact that they know
there is a compulsion that is a part of
her programming that had if she had all
of her uh rational capabilities she
might
dial that back she might tamp that down
a little bit it's just that
you try to turn that up to 11.
yeah so that those are two big takeaways
like try to have some insight into
yourself and then try to be playful with
it
um
before we started recording we talked
for example a little bit about female
hypergamy which is
you know women tend to be attracted to
guys who have relatively high dominance
or status or prestige or fame or
whatever
that's another thing where you can kind
of role play that stuff up
in a relationship so you can kind of
create
hypergamy
even when it doesn't really exist
at some objective level
and
uh you know people unlike the bdsm and
king communities do this all the time
with what they call power exchange where
it's like okay
the you know the man's gonna pretend to
have
some role
like he's the president or he's a ceo of
something and then the woman's gonna
pretend to be like
whatever the um secretary the white
house staffer secretary like whatever
whatever melts your butter
like you can do that
and it can actually help
your stupid human brain think
oh yeah my mate is actually really cool
and like really powerful
like
if more people did that i'm i'm
convinced that most relationships would
be at least 50 happier that's [ __ ]
interesting
a lot of what we've been talking about
vincent harren ammon who is rob
henderson's co-writer on some coilette
articles data scientist that's applied
his data science to looking at
dynamics in the market dating market at
the moment and um yeah there's this sort
of ongoing women are outperforming men
everywhere at the moment in education
you can have two to one women uh versus
men in four-year us colleges by 2030
women earn 1 11 pounds more than a man
between the age of 21 and 29 on average
at the moment um
and the the issue that you have if you
try and look at it from like a public
policy perspective and it's so
it's so interesting that i i thought
that you had to come up with a real
world rational solution to this
but the way that your brain interprets
the situation your brain isn't this
[ __ ] all-seeing all-knowing
thing you can
use the same tricks that it's trying to
play on you against itself
and if little you know if you do have
that high-powered boss [ __ ]
lady that's got herself into a
relationship with a man who you know
doesn't earn two million as much
whatever it is that she does um the fact
that you can compensate for that by
reversing the polarity
in the bedroom
is
that's really really [ __ ] interesting
yeah and there's
um
yeah that like the the new ag tantric
concept to polarity is something also
most guys should learn more about like a
masculine feminine how would you how
would you introduce that to someone
um
just the idea that
if you play up the the differences and
the tension between
sort of the masculine uh role and the
feminine role that's actually quite a
bit hotter
um
than
trying to achieve like similarity and
equality
particularly in the bedroom but in
relationships generally
uh so if you go to burning man right
you'll hear a lot of people talking
about
man you gotta you know get into your
masculine polarity and and
rediscover your uh your jungian shadow
blah blah blah and like there's a lot of
nonsense wrapped around it but i think
there are some deep evolutionary roots
to some of that wisdom
why do we find beautiful people
attractive do you think
i think beauty is partly
a legit indicator of
health fertility youth um
you know capacity to reproduce
but then there's certain parts of beauty
in our species and lots of other species
that are kind of arbitrary
like the fact that we have green or blue
eyes
rather than dark eyes if you're from
like a northern european population
is that really adaptive in terms of like
promoting um survival better or is it
just
oh if you migrate to a northern latitude
out of africa 150 000 years ago
you don't need a dark iris anymore to
protect your iris from bright sun
you're free to evolve all kind of crazy
new colors
like blue and green and hazel like why
because it's new and different and
apparently our ancestors thought that's
kind of cool
so
eye color might be one of those sexually
selected traits
that's a little bit
like
arbitrary likewise maybe red and blonde
hair color likewise
you know a lot of the facial feature
differences between like
africa europe um east asia
who knows why they evolved so i think
beauty is like half
really about fitness and health and half
a little bit arbitrary
what are the traits that we usually
enjoy someone doesn't understand sexual
selection from a fitness signaling
perspective what are the typical traits
that people enjoy
well when tucker max and i wrote that
mate book we we put a lot of emphasis on
just overall competence like what is
attractive about a guy uh to a woman
just he can do stuff effectively
capability competence and in the in the
physical domain
that's like
does he look like he could actually hunt
an animal successfully
could he run can he jump over stuff
could like couldn't he throw things
could he drag back a hundred pound
gazelle
from five miles away
if he doesn't look like he could do that
like why would you mate with him because
you know if you're a woman in prehistory
and you've got
babies
one of the main roles for the guy is
provide meat
you know provide resources
and any guy who looks like he's not
going to be a good hunter
is not going to be very attractive
sexually
likewise he should look like he can
potentially protect you
against other men
who might want to
kill your baby or you know rape your
woman or
um fight against your tribe
so
if you look like you're capable of
defending someone then that's attractive
and
i think a lot of it just boils down to
that like what are the physical cues
that that mean
you know you look like you'd be a good
bet for a long-term mate who's capable
of having kids providing for them
protecting them
and um you know helping them grow
what do you say to the people that go
jeffrey that's dumb
i don't need a man to drag an antelope
500 meters anymore this is the real
world in 2022 and
this doesn't matter anymore
i'd say that's
that's largely true objectively but
it can be quite hard to rewire your
brain
to say oh actually i i'm really
attracted to
like
guys who are five foot two rather than
six foot two
like fine you can do that i don't know
that many women who are successful at
doing that
and you know the the data from dating
apps says
height is a major predictor of
attractiveness on dating apps income
major predictor for men
um
so
on the one hand if you're a smart
woman
you can use
the evolutionary psychology insights to
go okay even though he's only five foot
four
he's great on these other like a dozen
other dimensions
you can leverage that to overcome
your kind of aversion to shortness right
and that can be really good just like a
man could
you know overcome aversion to some
you know issue that a woman has it
doesn't actually matter now
um
like maybe she's got some disability
she's missing an arm from a motorcycle
accident whatever it is like
there are ways you can kind of hack your
your your brain to say that's okay given
all the other
traits that are that are good in this
person
but man if you don't have an
evolutionary perspective how do you do
that that hacking of your own brain you
don't even know where these preferences
come from
so it's extremely hard to change them
what about from
men to women what are men looking for
it depends a lot
on whether men are looking for a
short-term mate or longer-term mate
we know what men are looking for in a
short-term mate right it's basically
cues of youth and fertility and sexual
accessibility and
you know we're descended from male
ancestors who are kind of scanning the
environment for like
where's an easy way to have extra
reproductive success with minimal
investment
that would basically be
any young healthy woman who seems like
fit and fertile and relatively
like unchoosy
right
that's like minimum investment maximum
roi
but then for long-term mate you know if
you're actually going to pair bond with
someone
stick around raise kids with them then
men get a lot choosier
about women's uh mental traits like
intelligence and creativity and sense of
humor and women's
like emotional traits like stability
and
conscientiousness
and reliability
um
and and about women's social status like
does she have a lot of friends what's
her family like um
is she socially savvy can she be a good
kind of um
almost political companion
where we can be like the tribal power
couple
but i think it's important like it's
really important for men to understand
the short versus long-term difference
because if you don't
you end up choosing women for the short
term attractive traits
and then you get stuck in a relationship
with them
and then you're like oh no
she's like
neurotic and not that smart and a bad
match but
sexy
but
the sex is great for a while
until it isn't
so i think again the better that men
understand this you know the easier it
is to sort of
be honest with yourself about what are
you really looking for
and what length of relationship are you
are you seeking
i had a conversation about this the
other day talking about the difference
between beauty and hotness
now you might have different terms for
it in the literature but uh an immediate
very sexually available signal of
fitness versus a more timeless graceful
more subtle signal of fitness
and um
i am absolutely adamant that society is
signaling almost exclusively of hotness
at the moment that the inherent
transactional transient nature of most
of young people's relationships where
basically they're masturbating with
somebody else's body uh and they just
there happens to be another
consciousness in the room
um
that that is leading into
hotness being
used as the fundamental cue so look at
i don't even know if these magazines
exist anymore but you know if you were
to get a girl on the front of some lad
mag some boys mag that's got fast cars
and like scantly clad women they're not
selecting for beauty they're
purposefully selecting for hotness i did
two reality tv dating shows i did love
island and one called take me out
and on that the same they're not
selecting for women that are beautiful
that's not to say that some of them
aren't or weren't beautiful but the
primary value that they're selecting for
is hotness because they only have six
weeks if you only get six weeks in a
villa and you have to share a bed that's
half the number of beds that there are
people so you're sharing a bed with
somebody every night um and they need
you to switch switch switch
there's a two eliminations a week and
all this stuff um they need they need
hotness you can't you can't have
something that takes you three months to
fully appreciate all of the nuances of
louisa's
[ __ ] back arch it's like no no no the
the half sleeve tattoo and the lip
piercing will do it for you straight
away
yeah exactly and
there's an there can be enormous
pressure to kind of signal hotness so i
think tattoos and piercings and certain
kinds of you know dressing in a certain
way
that basically advertises
like i'm you know potentially open to
short-term mating what do you think it
is
what do you think it is about piercings
and tattoos what do you think's the
subtext behind that
i think it's a little bit
it's a little bit culturally arbitrary
that it it has become associated with
openness to
kind of short-term mating or
you know openness to being open or
polyamorous or whatever
openness to threesomes whatever whatever
you're into
um but once you get the signal
established
once there's kind of a social consensus
that
oh if you have a lot of tattoos
that's signaling a degree of sexual
openness that would not be welcome in
salt lake city among the mormons
you know but would be welcomed in like
brooklyn or l.a or whatever
but i think your point about hotness
versus beauty is is
really
uh
on on the money and
like some women are so beautiful like
whatever cate blind chad or anne
hathaway or certain actresses like that
where it's it's like almost hard to
sexually objectify them
like it feels almost wrong to sort of
put them in the category of like
oh she's so hot
because classy beauty
you immediately think oh i wish i had a
wife like that
right or i wish i had a girlfriend like
that
um
i suspect there's something parallel
with men where like certain men
radiate
kind of like
short-term hotness rather than like good
long-term husband potential
you probably encountered this in the
modeling world a little bit correct and
in the nightlife world a lot dude i mean
because i see
it's so funny you know when you go into
a nightclub and there's a strobe light
on and you don't actually when there's a
strobe light you don't see people move
you see snapshots of the person it's
they're here then they're here then they
hear it then they're here um and running
a club night is exactly the same as that
but socially so i only get to see people
for five hours on a thursday and a
friday or whenever it is that your
particular portfolio of events is
running for that season or that year or
whatever and you see
things happen so you'll see
um new group of fresher students arrive
and then maybe this guy and this girl
maybe they meet each other and then
maybe they hook up and then maybe they
start talking and then maybe
they're together for a bit and then
maybe this new girl comes in and but you
don't see everything happen you just see
kind of like this brief window into it
and dude it's so
[ __ ] interesting to see to be able to
select the kids
that are going to be the ones
that are going to have the status that
are highly regarded
and you're right i mean there's
something
there's something around girls that wear
those choker necklaces
that have been accused of being a black
belt for [ __ ] by
not me um and
you you see that
certain signals play out
and that's what creates the stereotypes
culturally you know you see something it
gets reinforced and then maybe people
see that and think well i've just got
out of a relationship with a boyfriend
why don't i get a nose ring and start
wearing choking necklaces because that's
what the culture is telling me that sort
of person does and it
it just starts to feed itself
yeah and i think
i would just caution young people like
what you want is you want maximum
flexibility to adjust your signals
that you're sending out
in a way that is like dynamic and
adaptive if you get a permanent tattoo
that's visible
in every job interview
or
at
your wedding or whatever
like it's hard to go back from that it's
hard to do tattoo removal whereas if
you're wearing you know black belt
choker at least you can take that off
and like then become respectable on
monday don't need to still wear it at
the wedding yeah
so
um
like the of course the more permanent
the signal the more credible a signal it
is because it shows extra commitment
but i think a lot of young people really
like they have a very short-term time
horizon and they're really not thinking
ahead about how is this tattoo really
going to look in 15 years is my future
toddler going to make fun of it
talk to me about um
hard to fake versus easy to fake signals
of
of fitness and prestige and stuff i find
that really interesting
yeah i got kind of obsessed with this
branch of uh economic game theory called
signaling theory back in the late 90s
and it had a big impact on most of what
i wrote since then the basic concept is
if you're trying to signal
something like you're a male animal and
you're trying to signal i could fight
you i could win
right
the most reliable signals are the ones
that are hard to fake where there's some
pretty strong connection between
like the trait you're trying to show off
like formidability
or capacity for violence or body size
pretty strong connection between that
and the actual signal that you're
displaying
right so a lot of animals will kind of
fluff themselves up and make their hair
stand on end or if they have feathers
they'll like make a big show of it
so they're exaggerating their body size
to intimidate rivals
but there's still a correlation
between like your wingspan and and
like the part of your body they can
actually fight
um
now at a kind of like
uh cultural level
i did a whole book called spent
um in 2009 it was about conspicuous
consumption
and there it's more often a matter of
i'm going to buy and display some
particular good or service
that is objectively expensive in order
to show off i can afford it
and there like the credibility of the
signal depends on
like
is it real like is it actually a
designer handbag or a real rolex or is
it fake
and
do you really own that bugatti or did
you just rent it for the weekend
right
and so
you know people seeing this stuff are
naturally kind of skeptical
like if you see somebody wearing what
looks like a rolex
but everything else in their life is is
kind of like shitty and cheap
then you figure that's probably fake
um whereas if someone's already famous
for being a billionaire
and like you can easily google them and
you can see their net worth
then they can just wear you know
terrible henley shirts or whatever and
nobody cares
because they don't have to signal
through consumerism
i learned
i can't remember the scott alexander
blog post he did a glorious blog post it
wasn't i can't tolerate anything except
the outgroup it was something similar to
that where he talked about the fact that
if you have um four layers two classes
that
the top layer can use any of the bottom
two's fashions but it can't use the one
below and the same thing goes for
everybody else is trying to signal that
they are but then you get counter
signals which is the person at the very
very top cares so little and you see
this in hipster culture especially in
the uk now dude
some of the outfits that guys and girls
go out wearing
where the actual living [ __ ] did you get
those clothes from they look
terrible but it's a signal of i'm so
cool
i don't need to adhere to
your idea about what cool is
my cool is so huge and [ __ ]
compensatory it has its own orbit that i
can still be cool even whilst wearing
this 30 year old mothball ridden fleece
yeah exactly
and the counter signaling um
which is where like
you would normally expect someone to
signal in a certain way but actually
they're kind of signaling the opposite
but
the viewer is savvy enough to figure out
that oh they could have done the usual
signal
but they're intentionally
not
and like high fashion oat couture is an
interesting case where
basically you take like a 19 year old
you know six foot tall super beautiful
model and you put something absolutely
ridiculous
like truly absurd on her
and as long as it required like at least
you know 5 000
person hours of effort to do all the
stitching
then you can sell it to like
a 50 year old socialite
who doesn't actually look that good
right
and
that to me is very bizarre because um
you basically have like clothes that are
so ridiculous that only truly beautiful
fit women can wear them but they're
being bought mostly by women who aren't
and and that's kind of sad
social proof's an interesting one i
think that's kind of been co-opted as a
part of high value
now high-value men and high-value women
but i find social proof to be quite
interesting coming from a nightlife
background because that's what we're
playing off you know i need to get
each year in order to run my business i
need about 300 to 400 kids between the
age of 18 and 21 that are the ones that
are cool that are in the know that are
going to the right parties that are
sleeping with the right people that are
sniffing the right drugs or whatever
like they they need to that that's the
social proof and then we've um
commercialized that we've utilized that
to reflect what it means to go to voodoo
events right you go to voodoo events
event and but that's the one that's run
by the really good looking canadian kid
or whatever it might be um but social
proof happens on an individual level too
right
yeah totally it
in my experience like evolutionary
psychology was one important red pill
but marketing
understanding marketing and branding and
how influencers work was another major
red pill and i i think it's
also crucial for
people to understand
particularly in a modern social media
economy where
you know influencers are really driving
um a lot of the desirability of goods
and services or experiences like going
to particular club
and
we are just such
hyper social
primates who are just so tuned into
these cues
that it's
it's kind of easy to manipulate that
and just you you find the attractive
people and associate them with a
particular brand and everyone's like oh
you're so it's cool dude
that's that's our industry
yeah that's what nightlife is so there's
a lady ashley mia's you familiar with
her
oh she she wrote an awesome book uh
she was previously a
top model in new york up until the age
of about 25 but she was always at uni
doing sociology throughout left became a
professor
and then decided to do ethnographic
research becoming a party girl so
31 years old still very good looking
girl but now 10 years older than the
girls that she's going out with and they
were um the ones that were filler girls
so they got taken we don't really have
this so much in the uk a little bit in
london but not so much um there would be
a host of an event that would get the
girls and they'd go and get sushi or
whatever like the the after dregs of the
sushi and then you'd take them into the
club and they'd sit on the tables with
the guys that were spending money so
that they would feel and that's your
conspicuous consumption thing but
that
insight around
girls being used to
change the experience even though the
guys that are on the table know that
they're kind of not there with them
but it's a signal
it's not conspicuous consumption is it
what's is that kind is that that um
status and prestige by being associated
with beautiful women therefore i am as
well is that what's going on
well there's a lot of mate choice
copying dynamics where like a lot of
species
if you're male and some female is
like clearly interested in you then the
other females nearby will pay attention
to that
and they'll imitate
the mate choices made by
the other female particularly if the
other female is like more attractive or
older or more more experienced and so
you've got like this winner take all
thing
like beatlemania right where everyone's
like oh my god he's so cool why just
because all the other people think he's
cool
you know justin bieber who
um
this doesn't happen as much
with
men being attracted to women but it it
does also happen
there and it's a it's another thing that
you can exploit in marketing of course
an article came out in psychology today
yesterday uh the result of this exercise
and study was that three traits emerged
as general necessities kindness physical
attractiveness and good financial
prospects so that was both male and
female there was variation men tended to
view women's financial prospects as a
luxury and only eastern women saw
religiosity as a necessity you see that
it only came out yesterday
didn't see it dude i'll send it to you
once once we're done it's really really
[ __ ] interesting so they had a bunch
of different criteria for men and women
west and east and looked but across them
all
you did have some fairly universals
kindness physical attractiveness and
good financial prospects
i think humor was the one that just
about got missed off as well
yeah and if you if you dig down a little
bit into those three traits and you're
like whoa why would that matter well
physical attractiveness is pretty
closely associated with health
and longevity which is like
okay how long could i potentially be in
a relationship with this person like
before they get sick and die
so it's kind of a time dimension
the resources to mention is like
how much could they potentially
give to me or help support me or like
transfer to me that would be useful
to me and like
my kids and our life
and then kindness is like
will they actually
transfer those benefits to me
or withhold them for themselves or give
them to somebody else right
so if you kind of multiply like
how long could the relationship last
times how big are the resources times
like what proportion of the attention
and investment do i get
like that kind of covers a lot of what
you want from a long-term mate it's a
pretty good [ __ ] function yeah
it's a pretty good heuristic and like
it's okay to
it's not like we're doing some excel
spreadsheet where it's like i have to
rate all potential mates on the
following 200 traits and like do a
weighted linear model and like weigh it
up and then
like choose the best one i know
rationalists who do that literally
but you can achieve like
a decision that's like 95 that good
based on just a handful of simple traits
yeah
i i remember tweeting you i think it was
probably two years ago just as i'd
started to really get into evolutionary
psychology and i had a problem that um
the more that i saw the more i couldn't
unsee
yeah and i can't remember what your
advice was i'm sure it was great i
haven't forgotten it because it was
rubbish but i think it was something
along the lines of like it gets worse
before it gets better
you start to see things because one of
the criticisms that
i i understand this you know i i try and
put this across when i'm talking about
these dynamics is that
i'm not trying to be dispassionate about
this i'm not saying that there isn't a
place for
love and a sense of phenomenological
existential connection with somebody
that you genuinely care about i'm not
trying to reduce it down to the you know
the autistic excel spreadsheet um
but there is a there is a big period
where you go through kind of
seeing things
for what they are for the signals that
they are or for the reasons that
people's motivations have them to do
this
what what would you say to someone that
begins tumbling down the evolutionary
psychology dating dynamics rabbit hole
and starts to kind of i don't know is
there like a a nihilism like when people
learn about free will is there an
equivalent nihilism that happens with
evolutionary psychology
it can it can be tough for for a while i
i do think there's a little bit of a
like a dark valley that you go through
that's basically like
you know maybe you read the moral animal
and you read some david bostoff and some
steve pinker stuff and you read
yeah the the the apes that understood
the universe by steve stewart williams
great book i've actually used that as
required textbook and some courses dude
that what a [ __ ] great textbook
yeah yeah it covers so much it covers
like 80 percent of fpsyc in a really
digestible way
so
good to steve stewart williams for doing
that
so
i've seen this a lot you you get
undergrads
and they learn these things
and they can get kind of despondent and
kind of depressed for a while
it might last a few months or they might
like take a course
and then come back a couple years later
into office hours and go
wow the first year after i learned about
ebsyc was rough like i saw
all this stuff going on in a new
new light
and i became very cynical
about people's
motives and their their self-deception
and all their little stratagems and all
their [ __ ] and i saw through it
but then
um how do you come out of it you um
once you start living with the idea that
humans are just like animals
like other species
and you get used to that and then you
can start to see but what extraordinary
animals are we like it's so awesome
other animals just running around
doing all this sexual competition [ __ ]
and all this mate choice [ __ ] and based
on really
dumb traits like
oh i want to have sex with the bigger
gorilla not the smaller gorilla or the
bird with better plumage
and it's like oh at least we have the
blessings of being able to talk
and be creative and do art and music and
humor and all this other amazing stuff
and
we have a form of romantic love that is
like really sweet and very emotionally
intimate compared to what most other
animals do
and then you start seeing the bright
side
and then you can kind of get excited
again about human life
what's your thoughts on the manosphere
i have mixed feelings about it but
largely positive
like um
i've been a sort of uh
observer of it for like 15 years or so
ever since the early days of like pickup
artists in the early 2000s and
um
uh david deangelo aka
evan pagan is a good friend of mine and
i've like appeared at david angelo
events
like 15 years ago
it was
strange to see like
second and third hand
ideas from like my early work
getting kind of recycled into manosphere
like wisdom or or good advice or often
bad advice
uh and then get into arguments with
manosphere guys who are like miller you
don't understand human sexual dynamics
at all this is my [ __ ] word like
preach let me preach let me explain to
you how sexual selection works like dude
you're literally quoting back to me
something i wrote in 1994
like thanks but
i think for a lot of young men um
they need
like
older successful role models who can
explain this stuff to them in a very no
[ __ ] unpretentious way
you know and that's what tucker max and
i were trying to do with our mate book
it was kind of like conjoined
evolutionary psychology with
like brutally simple
language
that even your average like 20 year olds
could understand
and
you know sometimes the manosphere
guys get a little bit
um
overconfident i don't know what's up
maybe their testosterone supplementation
is too high or whatever but
they get a little feisty and a little
combative but
um
i just think if you're if you're a young
man listening to this it's
it's important to choose your role
models
uh carefully
and like try to choose guys who are
actually
succeeding at something other than just
giving advice
like who can actually have good
conversations with a variety of people
on their podcast or actually are making
money in crypto or have actually founded
some company that's doing well or
um
who aren't just like anonymous behind
the scenes kind of
manosphere trolls
the thing that surprised me when i was
watching uh reading mate your book which
is [ __ ] dope by the way if there are
guys out there that want to kind of
learn the principles of evolutionary
psychology for mating and i think that
women should read that book as well
because
where are all the good men at is
probably a pretty fair question to ask
at the moment and if you want to be able
to coach whoever it is that you're with
in order to be better or to be able to
understand what it is that you actually
want
really really [ __ ] good book it'll be
linked in the show notes below um but
one of the things that really surprised
me about that book was how long you guys
spent in a dating book for men
explaining to men about what it feels
like to be a woman in the dating space
that was
that was a like a really really welcome
surprise one of the problems that i have
the specific problem that i have with
the manosphere is it treats women like
the enemy fundamentally
that is the primary problem that i have
with it and i really really try to toe
the line i'm happy with uncomfortable
insights right i'm [ __ ] all day i'll
talk about them because they're cool
like watching the fallibility of your
own world crumble in front of your eyes
is this something kind of humbling about
that like we're looking up at the night
sky right like it's all and it's dread
at the same time it's kind of cool
but
you can push that so easily you know the
hypergamous nature of women that they
really don't have that much control over
and saying oh you are actually only a
five out of ten so you shouldn't be
thinking you need to get with a man that
does that's homeless and lives on a
couch and smokes weed all day like
all right man like is that not being
[ __ ] done to death where you get
idiot thoughts from miami and put them
on a podcast and do whatever but yeah
there's a big section where you try and
explain to men about what it's like to
be a woman um understanding girls
feelings around physical safety
objectification
creeps being self-conscious and stuff
like that and that is so [ __ ]
important i think for men to understand
yeah tucker and i did you know
a podcast called mating grounds we did
like 250 episodes or something
and that
that insight about hey guys you know if
you want to have success with women
maybe
radical idea
maybe you should spend like at least a
nanosecond
trying to look at the world through a
woman's
point of view
and the number of guys we had call in to
that podcast going like wow i never
actually did that
like even though i have a mom and
multiple sisters and many like
ex-girlfriends i never actually thought
okay what would the dating scene be like
if i felt physically vulnerable
sexually vulnerable
if a lot of the guys who approach me are
straight up like sociopaths
and bad dudes because they're the only
ones who have the courage to be super
assertive
right so you get a biased sample of men
or online you're going to buy a sample
of like a lot more trolls than good guys
because trolls are very very active
and just like spend a minute thinking
about that and then think
how
how is him you know an honorable man who
has his [ __ ] together can you like
break through all of that noise and and
chatter and fear
and kind of like present yourself as
hey how you doing my name is blah blah
um
just like have a normal conversation
so
perspective taking is
i think really crucial
in this
what do you think there's a about the
zero-sum mentality that i said about the
manosphere because that's how it feels
to me it feels to me
like
a lot of the
fundamentally um good
but delivered poorly
and with a snide topspin advice from men
sees any man's gain as a woman's loss
like it's it's weird that a lot of the
time they're talking about um how to get
women and to get with women and then
when a woman does does this sort of
low-key admission that that's somehow
their loss
like because you gave yourself away to
this guy that we've coached to try and
get himself into the position of how he
can have sex with you now you're a [ __ ]
yeah
yeah that's totally toxic it's bizarre
and
the
the irony is a lot of the guys in the
manosphere if you ask like do you
believe in capitalism or like
communism and redistribution they're
like capitalism why oh because like
economic exchange is positive some
because we can all get wealthier if we
like provide good good goods and
services to each other
and then you're like okay that makes
sense in economic markets why do you
think the mating market is somehow
zero-sum
like this there's some obvious
low-hanging fruits like if you have
dating apps that are really really good
at matching people based on
genuine compatibility
that's a win-win for everybody
it's way better
than living in some medieval village
where you have three potential mates and
none of them share your interests
and probably can't even read
right so there's there's so many
positive some
uh
ways we could we could restructure the
mating market to work better for
everybody
i took a quote from mate and i put it in
a newsletter the other day so i'm gonna
two of
both of our obsessions game theory
and um dating dynamics um so this was to
do with slut-shaming
uh female promiscuity has a tragedy of
the commons effect in the mating market
if one woman offers blow jobs on the
second date it's harder for other women
to keep them in reserve until the fourth
date is their special treat this creates
a downward spiral of young women feeling
like they have to offer more sex and to
more guys just to stay in the mating
game thus slut-shaming is a way of
enforcing a more restrained sexual norm
on other women so that not all women
have to become more promiscuous than any
one of them would like
that [ __ ] [ __ ] blew my mind
and
it's really it unless you have this kind
of game theory perspective it's really
hard to understand why [ __ ] shaming is
mostly done by women to other women
correct it also makes a lot of sense
around why women tend to be the
enforcers of [ __ ] shaming because so
frequently because women are the ones
who have an incentive to protect the
sexual marketplace from becoming a price
war of easy sex
yeah
and this is also why you know the main
opponents of sex work are often married
women
right because they have the most to lose
a husband goes off you know and
spends money on an escort or
some financial dominatrix or whatever
and
if you just ask like okay where are
people's incentives you know what's the
incentive to impose a certain social
norm on
human sexuality often it's not that hard
to figure out why it's happening
there's another case i did a little bit
of research around who opposes abortions
mostly
and it's women
there are more women that oppose
abortions than there are men
and i think there it a lot of that might
be a
a bit of a virtue signal right because
if you're
if you're a woman is like babies are
sacred
we have to protect babies it's kind of
like a way of saying my maternal
instincts are better than yours and i'm
going to be a good mom and one way i
demonstrate i will be a good and devoted
mom who who will you know protect your
babies
is
to insult other women who
seem not to protect
their fetuses
and you know i did a whole book on
virtue signaling so i think a lot of
this is um
just all the ways we demonstrate like
we're morally good people
and so you can trust me and i'm i'm good
and
you know you you and i are both pretty
active on twitter and honestly like 60
of the [ __ ] on twitter is virtue
signalling to me oh i would say probably
even more
most of the time people aren't saying
the thing that they're saying
it's just a signal around the thing that
they think they're supposed to say
here's how i see that that play out so
much
very rarely do you ever see someone
respond to a tweet let's say that
there's a back and forth of trying to
dunk on each other
nobody i i can't remember the last time
i saw it where someone said
that is out of [ __ ] order like you
can't say that nobody ever wants to get
to the stage where they
call a stop to the game
because the cool thing to do on twitter
is be this dispassionate [ __ ] edge
lord that just replies with memes of
kathy griffin like kathy newman uh or
kathy griffin um
because that's what's cool because the
signal is i'm so unperturbed by this
i've got so much other stuff that i
could be doing you're getting one
percent of my attention as opposed to
saying uh hang on a second
who the [ __ ] do you think you're talking
to that isn't an acceptable thing to
post to me
yeah my usual response when people just
get out of order as i just block them
like i blocked probably 30 people a day
but conversely
you know
you can almost feel yourself getting
swept up in that kind of edge lord like
um
game
i try to catch myself where
i think
you know what
once in a while at least a few times a
day i should be like
good point you're right i should look
into that more yep
it's hard to do though it's hard because
it's so [ __ ] hot it feels like you're
being submissive it feels like you're
you're losing
um but actually to onlookers
i think to a lot of people watching the
interaction
it's actually kind of cool to do that
jiu jitsu move of like
yeah we've been escalating this argument
but actually on this one issue you're
right yeah well that's a counter signal
right that i am exactly prepared to be
so humble yeah one of my favorite things
to do sometimes people have problems
with the balance of guests it's too much
too right wing or two male dominated or
two white or two whatever
and the only thing that i ever apply
with is
who would you like me to bring on
like give me tell me
tell me put it in the put it in the
comments tell me who you think that i
should bring on that fills the criteria
that you have got an issue with and the
it it's
i can't remember the last time that
someone responded to that they put a
dickish comment i asked a question
their reply is almost never dickish it's
almost always well actually here's a
list of five people that i think are
really interesting in some youtube
videos on where you get started ps
really love the show and you're like oh
okay we've managed to
neutralize this there's so there's a
lesson to be learned there i think about
de-escalating um
de-escalating aggression
yeah and you know twitter
to any psychologist is just such a
fascinating
like hunting grounds for insights into
human nature and um
that's one of the reasons i'm i'm so
active on it is i'm always like
partly involved as kind of a twitter
player but it's so easy to go meta and
to be like this is just
this is so funny like
eight billion primates running around on
social media just
like bashing each other verbally
and playing these little status games
and virtue signaling games
i want to finish off that slut-shaming
thing so i that's the first half of it
right that's what you guys put forward
in the book um and then i worked it
through using bro signs uh on my
newsletter uh reading that first section
about the fact that women enforce it
mostly and why you can't have the price
of sexual access kind of get spiraled
down and down reading that got me
thinking about the equivalent for men
and i think that it explains simp
shaming too
so i reword what you put at the top male
resource commitment has a tragedy of the
commons effect in the mating market if
one man offers gifts and resources by
the second date it's harder for the
other men to keep them in reserve until
the fourth date is their special treat
this creates a downward spiral of young
men feeling like they have to offer more
and more gifts and go on extreme
increasingly extravagant dates to more
and more women just to stay in the
mating game thus simp shaming is a way
of enforcing a more restrained
resource-giving norm on other men so
that not all men have to become more
resource-committed than any of them
would like similarly this explains why
men are mostly the enforcers of sym
shaming because men have an incentive to
stop symptoms from cheapening the value
of all men's resources it's hardly an
iron law men call women [ __ ] and men
women call men simps all the time but
this game theory explanation makes a lot
of sense to me if women give sex without
commitment it cheapens the value of sex
if men give resources or commitment
without sex it cheapens the value of
resources and commitment
yeah and you you can see this in some
weird little subcultures like financial
domination right
where
you might not be familiar with this but
there's a certain kind of online sex
worker
who's just like
i'm the dominatrix
you send me money
men who fetishize supporting women
will just send these women like
thousands tens of thousands of dollars
and they they sometimes they drip feed
it back to them as an allowance and
stuff right yeah and it
i don't really get it but
like whatever um
as long as you're not like a married guy
and you're taking money out of your your
mortgage account and sending it to some
other random woman
but whenever other guys hear about
guys who are into being fin domed
financially dominated like that's like
the ultimate
simp and then the the teasing is like
relentless
um i think there's even a bit of um
stigma about you know men who visit sex
workers
for the same reason
it's like how much are you paying like
why can't you just go to
you know chris's club and pick up a
woman what for for free whatever
um
but i think this this is what you know
cultural norms are is our
it's often our attempts to kind of
control the mating dynamics of other
people
why do you think it is that
men who work on
their charisma or their
abilities with women in like a an over
conscious way
why do you think it is that there's a
bit of an ick factor sometimes around
that both from men and women
i think it's a funny thing i don't i
don't know how much of that is kind of
unique to
like this particular cultural moment in
like british and american
uh mating dynamics i don't know how much
of it is just
a sort of like
innate wariness of any guys who give off
cues of being kind of machiavellian or
sociopathic or narcissistic
right there's this concept of the dark
triad personality traits
psychopathy machiavellianism narcissism
and so the guys who are high on those
dark triad traits do tend to care a lot
about like
good body how they dress how they act
you know maximizing like cues of
dominance and status that they display
and
kind of parlaying that into into mating
success
um
but
you know the guys who really benefit
from
like reading mate or reading manosphere
stuff are not typically those dark triad
guys
they're more often
guys who are kind of like
a little socially awkward and aspy like
me
or like i used to be and still am
where it's like i just don't understand
women i don't understand clothing how do
i get in shape
what is a conversation
like
doing kind of remedial
work on that i think is
you know that's a that's a huge win
because there's a lot of
guys out there with
amazing uh potential
that's not realized why because k-12
public education
doesn't teach any of this stuff
why would it
uh
male mentors like guys dads and uncles
don't seem to be bothering to teach it
well i think as well the the gap between
that generation and where we are now in
terms of what you need to know in order
to be effective in the mating market
this is one of the common criticisms
thrown around some of the guys in the
manosphere that
bro you've been married for [ __ ] 40
years
like you you literally got into a
relationship during a different like a
prehistoric era
yeah i think that is
like 50 accurate and 50
like a [ __ ] cope
because human nature doesn't change that
much yep i agree generation to
generation
it might be true that a lot of guys
dads and granddads and uncles
didn't actually have that much
like meeting experience themselves
right they might not have actually had
that many girlfriends they might have
only been in the mating market for like
two years before they married someone as
a college sophomore right
so they might not know what they're
talking about
but on the other hand
uh
you know to the extent that they've had
real life experience and mating
experience
um
there's no expiration date on on human
wisdom
about
sexuality
yeah just just because you're doing a
dating app and you're like
meeting people through you know
instagram or tick tock or whatever
does not
really change the basic
like traits that people are looking for
or the the trade-offs they're facing
i think one of the things as well
specifically on the guy's side is that
men
like to see proof of work or the
equivalent of proof of work right from
to use a crypto metaphor like
show me your workings where's your
where's your proof it's like having a
fat personal trainer like it's fine i'm
sure you can get me in shape but i'm
probably gonna have a little bit more
faith in the
in the trainer that's not fat
um and it's the same thing with this
that people want to see proof of work
why do you think i thought about this
loads i think there is a uh subreddit
called the pink pill but it's a little
bit more
like r women's rightsy
rather than
here are the fundamental principles of
evolutionary psychology that you should
use to become a more attractive better
balanced partner for the man that you
actually want to settle down with um
yeah why do you think that isn't
a pink pill
there really needs to be and i think an
awful lot of young women would be
you know hell a lot happier
if they had more
um insight into their own
preferences and desires and frustrations
and where they come from and how to
manage them better
my wife diana is working on a sort of
advice book for women
and i don't want to give away too much
information about it but what diana has
noticed
in reading many many advice books for
women
is that they're like 98 validation and 2
actually like you need to change this
right a typical like jordan peterson
book for young men is like
98 percent
you kind of suck and you really need to
get your [ __ ] together and here's all
the things you need to do because no
you're not actually a very good guy yet
and you can become that but you're not
women's advice books more often are like
you're awesome you're a queen like
you're wonderful and men don't
appreciate that yet and here's how to
manipulate them into appreciating your
your inner awesomeness
i think that's terrible like everybody
who's young needs to work on themselves
in all kinds of ways
so
i think the absence of a pink pill is
partly
young women are so used to being kind of
coddled
in terms of advice that they get
and i see this on in academia too in
terms of like how mentors treat grad
students
like you can give pretty brutal feedback
to
male students often
and they'll be like yeah you're right i
didn't work very hard on that paper i
need to fix it
uh it's extremely tricky to give
brutally honest feedback to a lot of
female students now
because it'll be like
you're just sexist you're patriarchal
like
does that actually have you seen this
happen
to colleagues or whatever
yeah yeah it's it's pretty common it's a
pretty
uh
[Applause]
and it's really handicapping
because like if you're trying to learn
how to
uh run a study or do science or write a
journal paper or
give a talk
like you really need a lot
of
brutally honest feedback to get better
it'd be like trying to become an olympic
um
you know skier
where your coach is always like
awesome ron oh another awesome run like
great turn uh
no you're not going to make progress
without clear feedback
so
i think there needs to be a little bit
of a cultural shift where
young women need to appreciate like it's
not actually doing you any favors in the
long run
to never get any any honest advice about
what you're doing wrong i wouldn't want
that either the girls that i know that
i'm friends with
would feel so [ __ ] patronized
if they found out
that because of other girls who were
kind of loading this sword of damocles
thing over the head of whoever it is
that was potentially going to give them
this feedback as soon as they stray into
an area that they think that
um which again presumably is allowed
minority that believe they're steering
the ship
if i if any of the girls i'm friends
with knew that that was happening they
would be very very unhappy there is a
big big chunk of them that just want to
become better and improve but i also
know exactly the books that you mean i
was looking i can't remember the title
of this book but it was like um
not gonna dress up for you or
uh
like
a girl doesn't wear high heels or some
[ __ ] like that pink and yellow and
[ __ ] fluffy front cover and the
entire thing was about how oh it was
like you don't deserve this something it
was all about how
everything that you're doing at the
moment in your dating life is completely
fine
and that you just need to keep on
plugging away with your current modus
operandi
until
you find the man that is going to be
right for you it's this like
[ __ ]
awful cocktail
of
molly coddling um
victim mentality
and
glitter
yeah like sparkly stuff
and yeah any young person who thinks
that they're
immune to this problem or that oh nobody
would ever you know call me
okay ask yourself the last three times
someone's broken up with you
have you asked them why
like have you done a like a
um
you know a debriefing
where you're like okay we're broken up
don't want to get back together but
please just spend half an hour giving me
your honest feedback about
everything i did that was stupid and
annoying that i can fix that's actually
under my control
like anybody who hasn't done that
with people they've broken up with
it's because you want to be coddled
like you're not willing to have honest
feedback
and
it's it's been great listening to uh
you know my wife diana
you know before we got married
if she would break up with guys she'd be
like would you like
would you like my honest feedback about
what she offered the debrief did she
she offered the debrief and often
because she tended to date
uh like rationalists and effective
altruists
it would be like yeah actually please do
tell me
do tell me
and that's great because she leveled a
lot of guys up
in terms of
you know they ended up with like much
better girlfriends after that than they
ever got before that
so this this kind of honest feedback can
be super useful but most people aren't
willing to seek it out
is there a
a reflection from this kind of molly
cuddling of women
into
you know we've
just seen that there is a vast majority
of women that aren't having children
there's
some stats around either divorces or
singleton-ness as well which are pretty
alarming
is there an equivalent on the male side
with
in-cell culture blackpill and mgtow
whereas women are retreating into a
community of women that are telling them
you will find the right man
they just don't deserve you babe
is the male equivalent to retreat into
you don't need a woman
we've got you let's just go get jacked
in the gym bro
yeah i think there's a there's a weird
kind of symmetry in in those reactions
but i think
just because there's an average sex
difference in kind of how you deal with
with negative information i think a lot
of the guys who are very frustrated by
the mating market
are kind of like oh all women are just
superficial gold diggers
okay i don't match their their traits i
never can i didn't buy bitcoin in 2012
when it was buck or whatever so it's
hopeless
and
then you
you know you go join a bunch of bitter
dudes and and hang out in their bitter
cave and you just
like yeah okay fine uh mating is
optional i guess
i had
i had
five grand of ethereum when it was a
hundred and ten dollars and sold it at
150 and thought that i'd have done the
deal of a lifetime
many such cases
i mean
yeah like the the crypto winner after
what early 2018 it's like who was who
was selling bitcoin at
two thousand dollars
millions of people were everybody
everybody was
and um
now they're all bitter about it and sad
and
and
but man those opportunities are still
out there by the way
not necessarily in bitcoin but in other
things this is not
investment advice but by cardano uh
there's a movement at the moment to ban
all dating apps because they
disproportionately
give a very small percentage of people
almost all of the success what's your
thoughts on that
you certainly get like that pareto
principle where like okay percent of
mating is done by whatever twenty
percent of guys or two percent of guys
but that's only the short term
meeting really
it's not like the top twenty percent of
guys are getting eighty percent of the
marriages
right so you need the right you need to
focus on the right metric if the metric
is
how many one-night stands is someone
having
yeah dating apps
are extremely unfair and they're very
much a kind of winner take all market
particularly from for males but also to
some degree for females
but to me that's not the relevant metric
the relevant metric to me is
who's who's getting together and forming
long-term pair bonds getting married and
having kids
and if you
if you focus on that i think a lot of
dating apps still have enormous
potential
to help people meet
other like-minded people
and like the weirder someone is the more
unusual their beliefs
the more useful
good dating apps could be
how do you mean
um
so like i happen to meet my wife diana
um you know in professional contacts and
like conferences and we work in the same
field
but after we started dating we thought i
wonder what our match percentage is on
okcupid
because we each used okay cupid
independently and we're like okay let's
compare
like huh
and we're a 98 match
and that was sort of like very validated
algorithmically reaffirming to us you
know
but the problem is okay how else would
like apart from working in the same
field how would we have found
each other apart from okcupid if we're
like
darwinian
libertarian agnostics
who are like into this and that kind of
sex and
have this and that weird set of
alt-centrist political views
you can't just go to a bar or a club and
expect to find
someone who matches on all those things
especially if you really care about
those those values as we did
so
if you're using dating apps and you're
like i just want to maximize one night
stands you're probably going to be very
frustrated
but if you view it as
this amazing way to find your future
spouse
you know who actually matches you on
stuff you care about
that's the thing that matters
that's
that's the story you're gonna tell your
grandkids in the future
what
pieces of dating advice do you think
that people should dispense with or do
you wish that more people were focusing
on when they're making their choices
with mates in 2022
i think people are
in innately somewhat attracted to
general intelligence
but i think a lot of men in particular
underestimate
just how incredibly useful general
intelligence will be in a long-term mate
and a woman
even if the woman does not have some
high-flying career
like
the amount of
life stress you can avoid
if your spouse is really smart
and decisive and well informed and has
some wisdom
is enormous in terms of raising kids
where you live
you know building a good social network
um being like frugal with money making
good investment decisions
um
handling health crises figuring out
should we worry about that lump that we
found or whatever
like there's dozens of domains where
general intelligence really cashes out
and
i would urge
like
most young men you should try you should
try to date smart and not just hot
because until you've
dated some really smart women
like for a while
and given their intelligence like the
chance to shine so you understand wow
there are a lot of hidden benefits to
this
until you have that experience you'll
kind of not pay enough attention to it
i like that what are you working on next
have you got anything coming up
um
i want to do some more psychology
research on uh global catastrophic risks
and existential risks because that's
been one of my passions the last few
years
i would really like humanity to survive
in the into the 22nd century that would
be cool
and um
there's a bunch of risks that are pretty
pretty scary that uh i think deserve a
lot more attention a lot more research
which ones what you focused on
um
i mean a lot of these risks are well
known to the rationalist community in
the effective altruist community like
you know
artificial general intelligence and
superintelligence
big potential x-risk um bio weapons and
pandemics and particularly genetically
engineered bioweapons big risk
um
nuclear war
is still
a major risk is is nuclear war a true
x-risk
i think it's it's certainly a global
catastrophic risk um
there's been a lot of discussion about
like okay which of these global
catastrophic risks that could actually
kill like all 8 billion people in a way
we can never recover from
nuclear war it might leave enough
little pockets of humanity that we could
bounce back
eventually but it would still be you
know
still be pretty bad
yeah it like it might mean oh we
colonize mars
in near 2600
rather than
2050.
um
so
the psychology of those is really
interesting because i think we have a
pretty accurate model of like what the
major
catastrophic risks are
but the human ability to understand
those is very very bad
like we do not have a good intuitive
grasp on any
risks that
like more people than just
like me my family my little tribe
we never evolved the the ability to be
long-termist about like what affects all
of humanity
so i would love to do more uh more
research on that where you you actually
like
use the behavioral science insights
to try to guide
um
public understanding of these risks and
also guide policy
what we do about it
man there was a brief period after i
read the precipice twice back to back
and i was already familiar with x-risks
a lot but
that that book just really really drove
it home
and it was it was like an existential
crisis from an existential risk book
where i read it and i was like
okay you know that this is important
you believe that this is important
what the [ __ ] are you doing with your
time that isn't screaming from the high
heavens to everybody that this is the
single most important task for everybody
to have their focus on like you should
stop doing podcasts about [ __ ] sexual
selection you should stop eating and
sleeping and you should spend your time
and whatever influence you have trying
to get people
it and it as soon as i watched don't
look up
i just immediately resonated with the
the scientists on that you know as
that's the job that i should be doing
and there's still a part of me man
there's still a [ __ ] bit of me that
goes suck it all off
turn the youtube channel into an
exclusively existential become like the
pretty boy gateway drug to x-risk
awareness and [ __ ] go for that and i
i don't man that that that entire
subject area terrifies me
it's super important and it's kind of a
it's kind of a downer
but
yeah maybe you should maybe you should
become pretty poster boy for x-rays
because like it it does need a lot more
attention um
and i have exactly the same reaction
like everybody watching this should go
read toby awards to precipice they
should also read daniel ellsberg's book
uh the doomsday machine about the risk
of nuclear war throughout the 20th
century uh and they should watch don't
look up after they read the precipice
yes
um
and
so how do you how do you get excited
about this and how do you find balance
in life i don't know like i've spent
thousands of hours learning about crypto
in the last 12 months
literally thousands about and like i
could have been running really great
psychology studies about
x-risk and i didn't um
well
partly you want to get
into a position where you've got
the social network and the financial
resources and the life skills and like
the the professional elbow room where
you can actually
have an important impact yeah yeah the
change needs to be magnified well that's
the argument of the
uh effective altruism movement right
that
you
jeffrey miller going and giving your
time at a [ __ ] local dog shelter or
something or flying off to africa
is not maximizing the impact that you
could have because you can generate more
of an impact monetarily by selling books
and doing talks and things like that and
then just giving it to the people that
can actually go and do that like the
specialization for work
uh but tuned up for effective altruism
and you are right there's
but dude i i i could absolutely see a
future in which
i dedicate a a big ton of time to just
trying to make that accessible if i was
to give
advice to the guys that are already down
that rabbit hole about existential risk
the thing that i think that they're
missing is a bunch of ways to
incentivize influencers and creators to
make it sexy and to make it interesting
you know it is a really really important
and these guys they're [ __ ]
rationalists right they know where the
blocks are they should be able to see
where they are and it's the fact that
tell me who
the influential existential risk
youtuber is
who the [ __ ] is it it's no it's not
there's nobody there isn't a person
that's doing it and yet it's potentially
the most important
subject topic that humanity's ever going
to deal with like that should be that
should be something that people focus on
yeah and it it could be other things
like uh
so there's like a lot of money and
effective altruism now there's there's a
lot more money than than talent
but there's a tendency in the
rationalist community to think
well the way you solve problems
is you you write like white papers for
your friends and like you do analyses
and you share like the inner esoteric
wisdom within the few thousand people in
that effective altruism community
and you don't really do public outreach
because there's an assumption that the
public couldn't handle it
right or if the public got alarmed by
this they would all go stampeding off in
the wrong direction like they might
go oh yeah the real x risk is like the
world might get two degrees celsius
warmer
yeah and they might not care about ai so
i get that but
this is the thing that's annoyed me the
most and ever since that table from
toby's book got put online i post it
around about every six months saying uh
this is your regular reminder that
climate change is not an existential
risk priority
and
people are concerned about the planet
it's obvious that you can weaponize
um societal concern about the future of
primarily not humanity mostly nature but
that you there is a compulsion in there
where people can think on that broad
scale right
it just happens to be that the first
[ __ ] movement that got a hold of that
was pointing at a risk
which is like what one in ten thousand
over the next hundred years one in
thirty thousand over the next hundred
years i think toby's got it in this book
it's it's nothing it's negligible one in
ten for
artificial intelligence one in ten for
bioengineered weapons one in 30 for
maybe nanotechnology and natural
pandemics
yeah like there you go
that's the [ __ ] focus do you care
about the dolphins do you care about not
being turned into [ __ ] paper clips
that's the problem yeah
yeah i think we're on the same page here
and so
i wish that some of that money
that war chest to fight x-risk went a
little more into social media outreach
and asking like how could we make this
like one of jordan peterson's top three
priorities how can we get like joe
rogan's talked about this a lot with
someone and nick has been on and and
like yeah but it's it's not like
it's not the major focus of a lot of key
public people
and it's weird because like the richest
guy on the planet elon musk this is his
entire [ __ ] deal ever since he was a
teenager we have to go multi
multiplanetary
to minimize existential risk so we don't
[ __ ] go extinct
and that's his driving motivation
and yet
for all the
you know the billions of people
who are kind of awestruck by spacex
only a tiny fraction of them even
understand why elon musk wants to do all
that
so yeah elon himself should do more
about this but i i think he realizes
like it's kind of a bummer and people
don't want to hear it
would you be up for coming back on and
doing a primer on existential risk at
some point like uh if you haven't heard
about it before if you don't know about
it here's what we need to know we can
just thrash that out for an hour and a
half or something
yeah that would be awesome i'm down
looks like you know i'm not an expert on
like all the technical risks but i think
i can provide some kind of evolutionary
context of like
um why
long-term survival of humanity is
kind of important
i'm down jeffrey miller ladies and
gentlemen people want to keep up to date
with what you do where should they go
primalpoly.com is my website um
and probably the best books if you're
interested in reading something i've
written as uh the mating mind or spent
or
mate or virtue signaling amazing they'll
all be linked in the show notes below
jeffrey thank you for coming on man it's
been a pleasure what's happening people
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace